HER.
>> IN OUR PLURALIZED NATION THAT
IT'S MY HOPE THAT THE FACTS WILL
WIN THE DAY, THE TRUTH WILL
ALWAYS MATTER, THAT JOURNALISM
AND GENERALIST WILL THRIVE.
>> Bret: SHEPARD SMITH, ALWAYS
SAYS BREAKING NEWS CHANGES
EVERYTHING.
THIS AFTERNOON BREAKING NEWS
CHANGES EVERYTHING, NEWS THAT
SHEP WAS LEAVING
FOX NEWS CHANNEL, LAST BROADCAST
TODAY.
I WORKED MY FIRST ASSIGNMENT
ALMOST 23 YEARS AGO.
HE ANCHORED BREAKING NEWS, CAST
MOVING EVENTS BETTER THAN ANYONE
FOR THIS PICTURE IS ACTUALLY OF
US AT THE PENTAGON, I'M AT THE
PENTAGON, LIKE PICTURES COMING
IN COVERING THE WAR IN IRAQ REAL
TIME AND WE ARE BOUNCING AROUND
THE WORLD WITH LIVE PICTURES.
HE DID IT BETTER THAN ANYBODY IN
THE BUSINESS.
FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS
FROM THE BEGINNING OF
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.